日本語字幕作成者：今日の一言
性感帯だ
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
今日は２人の協力者に来てもらっています
どうぞー
はいというわけで今回この大人数で何をしようかと言いますと
皆さん糸電話って知ってますか？糸電話
結構長い距離をやってる動画とかがいくつかあって
俺の見た中で最高の長さは100m
100mが糸電話のMAXでみんなやってたんですけど
やっぱ今はネット社会なので
もうどこにいてもLINE通話とか電話ですぐ電話できると思うんですけども
もしこの社会が危機に陥った時
我々はどうやって連絡を取り合うか
1000mの距離あったらどうやって連絡を取り合うんすか
取り合うんすか
1000m離れた人と電話どうするんすか
いや～全く遅い
LINEとかネットとか電話とか使えない状態でも
1000m先の人と会話できる方法を
僕は見つけておきたいと思いまして
近い将来のうちにね
というわけで今日は
糸電話を1000mで実験してみようと思います
場所はですね
今回
あそこら辺は人がいるんですけども
こっち側はもう人がいなくて
ずっと1直線で　直線で1000mくらい続いていると思われます
1000m分は多分準備してあるので
ここで実際に今回１０００mで糸電話をしてみようと思います
では行こう
あ、やばいやばい
でっかくね？ｗ
こちらが1000m分の糸でございます
こういう糸が一番音が伝わりやすいらしいので
これで今回やっていきます
2種類あると思うんですけど
まずは基本ペーパーなのでとりあえず紙コップで1回やってみましょう
カブトムシって7月がピークじゃなかったけ？
まさき：クワガタは早いけどカブトムシは遅いよ多分
はじめ：本当に？
こういう感じで穴を開けます
で、ここに糸を通します
わー、まさき無理かも
無理無理無理
作れないよ
こんなに難しいか？
ワクワクさんマジギレだよこんなん
あ、来た来たおｋおｋ
来ました来ましたおｋです
で、内側からセロハンテープで止めます
はいというわけで片方は完成しました
こういう感じに糸電話を作っていきます
糸電話片方完成したので
こっちを弟に持ってもらいます
こういう感じで余裕もって持ってもらって
で、この1000m分の糸を今から僕が
ずっとあっちまで行って
向こうで糸電話を作って
果たしてこっちと向こうの糸電話で
1000mの距離間を受信できるかどうか確かめてみようと思います
確かめてみようと思います
では行こう
糸電話をしようとしてるんですけど
はい
この辺はちょっとまずいですよね？
こっち側だったら？わかりました　ありがとうございます
はいというわけで早速今から1000m歩いていきます
では行ってきます
いや～あっ！
大丈夫？
はいというわけで始まりました
1000m糸電話でございます
はじめ：これ果てしなくね？結構
まさき：果てしないね
うお～すげー
これやばいよ
めっちゃ怖いね
どうなってんのこれ
わかんないわかんない
まさき：だよねｗ見えないよね
見えないもうわからない
えっと結構来たんですけども
ご覧ください
行く手を阻むテトラポッド達です
どうするんだ
一回見てこよう
これは海を越えるよ
テトラポッドに引っかかるのも怖いんだよ
これくらいなら大丈夫？
ぎりぎり超えれそうなのでこのまま行っちゃいましょう
よし行くぞまさき
直線だったらいいんだよね
まさき：この角度で行かないと・・・
まさき：もっとこっちだよね
まさき：わりとこのテトラポッドぎりぎりくらい
はじめ：こうか！
よし行こう
はいというわけでなんとかテトラポッドの闇は防げたと思います
上手いこと交わしたよね
多分なんとか直線にまでは繋いでると思うので引き続きこの先歩いていこう
行こう
ゴールは目前だ
俺たまにいつ結婚できるんだろうって思っちゃうよ
あ～もう結構終盤まじ
もうちょいで多分終わると思います
うん、じゃあね
もうほらもうちょい
はい皆さんご覧ください
もうすぐまじラスト
あーー
う～
あ～～まじまじあ＾～～～
まさき：ゆっくり行かないと
あ～～～
ひとまずここら辺で1000mでございます
優しい男性：熱中症になるぞぉ？
はじめの弟：すみません　ありがとうございます
こっち側でも糸電話作っていきます
あ～～きたきたきたおｋおｋ
完成しました
うおお張るね（戻ろうとする力が強くて）
というわけで実際に1000m先の人と糸電話で電話できるのか実験してみましょう
LINE電話中
はじめ：もしもし～？
はじめの弟：もしもし＾～？
はじめ：はいは～い
はじめ：一応1000m地点には到達しました
はじめ：引く力超強いじゃん
はじめの弟：引く力超強い
はじめ：どうすればいいと思う？
はじめの弟：どうすればいいｗ
wwwwwwwww
じゃあ紙コップごと結ぼうもう
こういうことこういうことこう　OK
じゃあ今からLINE電話切るから
紙コップにむかって大声で喋ってください
はじめの弟：はーい　はじめ：はーいでは
はいということで弟の声が聞こえると思います
聞いてみましょう
はじめの弟：もしも～し
はじめの弟：もしもし～
はじめの弟：もしも～～～し！！
はじめの弟：もしも～し
-完-
何も聞こえないや